hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for men women and
children from my understanding it's a
drama drama comedy let's face it drama
knees or more dramatic than they are a
comedy and I hear Adam Sandler to start
of this I really support dramatic Adam
Sandler nothing wrong I'm one of the few
people who seems to really like Adam
sandwich comedy yeah but I love his
dramatic work a [ __ ] punch drunk love
he was great in I loved him and rain on
me or rain on fire I don't remember it's
a movie with him in Denzel Washington I
know it's not them they'll trust me it's
Martin Lawrence idiots I really liked
him in funny people I thought in funny
people like he really brought that guy
to life like it was a great [ __ ]
performance in my opinion so I really
respect his dramatic work I always find
it believable you can make me cry
sometimes he's a great [ __ ] actor and
I feel like I identified with the roles
that he does that are serious so yeah
you know what I support this yeah
teenagers
highs
Oh what Oh badass
I'm strangely depressed and horny at the
same time
the trailer really up lifted my spirits
it's like closer but with families so
it's kind of more disgusting um good
teaser I guess it just looks like
everyone's having a shitty [ __ ] time
men women and children it's just doesn't
look happy I don't think it's a dramedy
i that just looks like pure darkness
it's strangely arousing at times it's
just time putting me in a weird mood to
be honest it's just so much like sexual
affairs going on here sexual affairs
freak me out you know it's like when you
meet people who are involved in sexual
affairs it's it's like why problem you
talk about what your partner or breakup
with your partner or get a divorce
because divorce can be a good thing if
you think about it because those are two
people who are not happy together so
it's better if apart but we do it we're
all insecure human beings we cheat we
horny when were teenagers
I like to be choking on having sex yeah
a child you slept maybe if you're
watching this video you know what to do
well guys thanks for telling me that
trailer was out thanks for depressing me
along with you if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects we do trailer reactions movie
reviews spoiler reviews for it films now
and again
vines vlogs I don't know why that movies
the trailers just making me question my
life it's really putting me in a weird
funk it's just a trailer - it's like I'm
getting extremely depressed yet it's
making me want to watch it I just want
to have sex right now
alright lot exploring put us shut up an
Thiago Marquez Fernandez hey man I need
a shout-out or girlfriend whatever comes
first
I'm on if I want the girl first you get
the money then you get that money and
then you get the power then when you get
the power then you get the girl huh so
harsh I don't um
do good Scarface impression that's the
best advice I can give you I mean what
you can do is you know you're asking for
a shout-out from a super
successful incredibly famous youtuber
right now I'm like at the top Jeremy
Jones Chris Stockman schmoes now but
with a flicker these guys I have thirty
thousand subs okay
that's huge in YouTube world and if I
give you a shout out then you could show
a girl not like hey this guy
acknowledged you that's [ __ ] hot dude
that any [ __ ] would want to bang you
you have to be a [ __ ] or [ __ ] they
they're the ones who care about the
superficial things but honestly you know
if you won like a good girl
you gotta work on yourself you got to
become a better individual you have to
you know attract a girl into your life
they see Laura habit queen you must
first become a king so you're like I've
been in a relationship for about one
week now and I know plenty about
relationships okay being a power
celebrity couple I can tell you that we
attracted each other into each other's
lives like that she worked on her
individual stuff I worked on my
individual self and then BAM we became
one look if you just want to have sex
dude trust me on this plan trust me on
this plan Roxie dxt M sub Brian can I
get a shout out been a fan since I saw
you react to the spider-man trailers the
other stuff you glued your eyeballs to
hi another thing I'm gonna jump on the
boat with everyone else by agreeing that
you and Veronica would look great
together all I can say is make the right
moves and she'll be on you like I don't
know just do what you do hope to meet
you someday yes Rock City XDM I hope to
meet you someday too
I love to meet you I live in California
you know as a matter of fact I live in
LA okay
always a big city but I'm trying to make
it easier for you to find me anyone if
you live in LA let me know Rock City XDM
you can subscribe for a while you rock
my city and sometimes I rock my girls
too Jason boss eight seven eight love
your vids they always make me laugh when
I'm down
oh they make me laugh when I'm down it
would be cool if you can give me a
shout-out if you do just say Mason Reese
you this is it Mason a secret society
where they do like creepy things like
anal probing and stuff I can't remember
but yeah I mean if you're part of that
secret society
cool good for you ma'am you should
should be proud of that
I've always want to be part of a secret
society I'm currently part of a secret
society actually now that I think about
it the veronik of society only I get
access to that there's one member and
that's me
don't forget that Mason may be wonderful
connect I really don't know if that
happens because that would be disturbing
for me and I'm sure for Veronica too so
hopefully you don't you know gain name
that girlfriend